MALE >> Should we have a code of ethics similar
to the ones we find for doctors and lawyers,
for CEOs? Of course we should! CEOs should
be held accountable just like doctors and
lawyers. For doctors we have the Hippocratic
oath stemming from Hippocrates in ancient
Greece. For lawyers we have the bar exam.
MALE 2 >> The Hippocratic oath tells doctors:
First, do no harm. It seems that modern corporate
executives don't follow 'First, do no harm.'
FEMALE >> CEOs should not have an ethical
code. This answer may seem odd. It looks like
the perfect solution since a lot of the current
economic mayhem has been caused by unethical
actions. But the code is not the answer simply
because we already have one. It's called the
law.
MALE 3 [BACKGROUND CLASSICAL MUSIC] >> It's
probably going to be really hard making a
code like that since every business is different
and you can't really make everybody follow
the same thing.
MALE 4 >> A common characteristic shared by
doctors and lawyers [TURNS COFFEE MUG PROPS.]
is that of serving others in society. This
is not directly true for CEOs. [BRINGS ANOTHER
MUG INTO VIEW.] Their goal is to make money.
So, yes, we do need a code of ethics for CEOs,
but not one like there is for doctors and
lawyers.
MALE 5 [BACKGROUND MUSIC] >> Company executives
should provide the leadership and the example
for the company. The ethics can be summed
up in one word: integrity.
MALE 6 >> The main issue here is a corporation
is a nonliving entity that has one sole purpose,
and that's to create money for the owners
and its shareholders.
MALE 7 [OUTSIDE WITH DOGS] >> Maybe what-ah-you
all in Davos can be talking about and discussing
is probably a little bit better governance,
a little bit better oversight and, dare I
say, a little bit more regulation. It seems
to me at least on this part of the world that
we have [DOGS RUN FROM RIGHT TO LEFT.] deregulated
ourselves into a great big hole and it's gonna
be a little while before we get out of it.
MALE 8 >> This oath of business should actually
come from the world economic forum. That again,
I think, is something that-ah-the world economic
forum can convene a group of experts...and
by world economic forum 2010-ah-for there
to be a press release and executive report
that would be issued to the public that this
is the oath of business that we have come
up with and that could be the legacy of the
world economic forum.